ED HENRY, I KNOW YOU'RE GOING TO
BE HEADED HOME TOMORROW.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR ALL YOUR
HARD WORK.
I KNOW YOU'VE BEEN WORKING LONG
HOURS.
JOINING US NOW FROM WASHINGTON,
REPUBLICAN CONGRESSMAN JIM
JORDAN, RON DeSANTIS ON THE
MAN WE QUOTED, MATT GAETZ.
CONGRESSMAN JORDAN, LET ME BEGIN
WITH YOU.
DO YOU KNOW, AS I'VE HEARD
DIRECTLY FROM PEOPLE, SARAH HAS
HEARD, CATHERINE HERRIDGE HAS
HEARD OTHERS AND GREGG JARRETT
THAT IN FACT WE HAVE ROD
ROSENSTEIN THREATENING,
INTIMIDATING TO USE THE POWER OF
THAT OFFICE TO GO AFTER PEOPLE
TRYING TO DO THEIR JOB.
>> I BELIEVE IT HAPPENED.
I TALK TO FOLKS WHO SAY IT
HAPPENED, WHO WERE THERE.
IF, IN FACT, THIS DID TAKE PLACE
WHICH I THINK IT DID, THIS IS
THE EXECUTIVE BRANCH THREATENING
STAFFERS OF A STANDING HOUSE
COMMITTEE TRYING TO DO THEIR JOB
AND GET ANSWERS FOR THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE.
THIS IS AS WRONG AS IT GETS.
THE FUNDAMENTAL QUESTION IT
RAISES IS WILL THE SPEAKER OF
THE HOUSE STAND UP AND DEFEND
HOUSE INTELLIGENCE COMMITTEE
STAFFERS?
THE BEST WAY TO DO THAT IN MY
JUDGMENT IS TO BRING UP THE
RESOLUTION THAT THE THREE OF US
INTRODUCED, MR. MEADOWS AND
OTHERS INTRODUCED COME EARLIER
TODAY ON THE HOUSE FLOOR.
>> I AGREE WITH YOU.
WHERE IS THE SPEAKER ON THAT?
HONORS BEEN RON DeSANTIS.
>> THIS CONDUCT IS DISQUALIFIED.
HE CANNOT BE THE DEPUTY
ATTORNEY GENERAL.
HE'S THREATENING PEOPLE WHO WORK
IN CONGRESS SIMPLY BECAUSE WE
ARE DOING OUR JOB TO TRY TO GET
ANSWERS FOR THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
THE ARROGANCE OF ROSENSTEIN, FOR
MONTHS AND MONTHS, TO STONEWALL
AND STONEWALL, NONSTOP.
EVEN BASIC ANSWERS TO REDACT
INFORMATION, IT'S GOT TO THE
BOILING POINT, WE IN
CONGRESS NEED TO ACT.
I THINK HIS POSITION THERE --
POSITION THERE IS UNTENABLE.
>> Sean: WHEN I AM HEARING,
CONGRESSMAN GAETZ, ONE OF THE
REASONS ROD ROSENSTEIN IS DOING
A LOT OF THIS IS BECAUSE THERE
ARE SPECIFIC DOCUMENTS WITH
SPECIFIC DAYS AND SPECIFIC DATES
THAT MAY IMPLICATE HIM.
HAVE YOU HEARD THE SAME THING?
>> WE HAVE, SEAN.
ROD ROSENSTEIN IS INTERACTIVELY
CONFLICTED IN THIS INVESTIGATION
CONFLICTED IN THIS INVESTIGATIO
INVESTIGATION.
AS BRAVE PATRIOTS LIKE KASH
PATEL WORK HARD FOR THE CONGRESS
TO EXPOSE THE CORRUPTION AND THE
BIAS, THEN THEY ARE THREATENED
BY ROD ROSENSTEIN?
THIS IS OUTRAGEOUS.
KASH PATEL WAS IN MY OFFICE,
CONCERNED FOR THE FACT THAT HE
COME AS A STAFF MEMBER, WAS
DOING HIS JOB AND THEN SOME
HIDEOUT DIFFERENT BRANCH OF
GOVERNMENT BRINGING THESE
THREATS UPON HIM.
LOOK, I AM SICK AND TIRED OF ROD
ROSENSTEIN'S GAMES.
I THINK WE NEED TO IMPEACH
ROSENSTEIN.
HE WON'T TURN OVER DOCUMENTS.
HE SIGNED A FISA RENEWAL GIVES
THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES AND FRANKLY IF WE
DON'T STEP UP AND DEFEND OUR
INSTITUTION, THEN WHAT GOOD IS
THE CONGRESS ANYWAY?
>> Sean: OKAY.
AND HE HAS HIS TEMPER, WHICH
HAVE ALL OF YOU HEARD ABOUT IT?
CAN YOU SHAKE YOUR HEAD?
I'VE HEARD ABOUT IT.
I THINK CHAIRMAN NUNES IS BEING
PRETTY NICE BECAUSE, YOU KNOW, I
JUST ASSUME HE DIDN'T WANT TO GO
ON THE RECORD.
BUT TO USE THAT POWER WE ARE
TALKING ABOUT HERE, HERE IS WHAT
I'M HEARING CONGRESSMAN JORDAN.
IT'S EITHER GOING TO BE THE
PRESIDENT DEMANDS THESE
DOCUMENTS OR CONGRESS HAS THE
OPTION OF IMPEACHING HIM.
THAT WOULD REQUIRE THE SPEAKER
TO STEP UP HERE.
BUT MORE IMPORTANTLY, WHEN DO WE
GET THE DOCUMENTS AND HOW DOES
CONGRESS DO ITS JOB IF THEY ARE
BEING INTIMIDATED THAT THEY ARE
GOING TO BE THE SUBJECT OF
HARASSMENT AND INVESTIGATION AS
RETALIATION FOR CONGRESS DOING
THEIR CONSTITUTIONAL DUTY?
>> SEAN, YOU ARE RIGHT.
THERE ARE CERTAIN TOOLS WE HAVE
IN THE TOOLBOX.
THEY SHOULD ALL BE AT OUR
DISPOSAL TO GET THE INFORMATION
WE CONSTITUTIONALLY ARE ENTITLED
GET TO GET ANSWERS FOR THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
IT'S REALLY THAT BASIC.
I THINK THERE ARE TWO
FUNDAMENTAL QUESTIONS.
THE FIRST ONE IS, THE REPORT
COMES OUT TOMORROW FROM THE
INSPECTOR GENERAL.
IT WILL HAVE PEOPLE IN THERE
THAT WILL BE CITED FOR
WRONGDOING.
WE'LL ROD ROSENSTEIN FIRE PEOPLE
WHO ARE CITED IN THE
INSPECTOR GENERAL'S REPORT FOR
WRONGDOING IN THE CLINTON
INVESTIGATION?
THE SECOND FUNDAMENTAL QUESTION
IS WHAT I HAVE RAISED BEFORE.
WILL THE SPEAKER OF THE HOUSE
STAND UP AND DEFEND PEOPLE ON
STANDING COMMITTEES THREATENED
BY THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE?
THE BEST WAY TO DO THAT IS TO
BRING UP THE RESOLUTION.
IF THEY DON'T COMPLY WITH THE
DOCUMENT REQUEST AND THE
RESOLUTION, THEN LOOK FOR
EXACTLY WHAT MATT GAETZ TALKED
ABOUT, CONTEMPT AND IMPEACHMENT
ARTICLES IN THE TOOLBOX WE HAVE
TO GO TO.
FINALLY, THERE IS WHAT DEVIN
NUNES SAID, THE PRESIDENT CAN
SAY RELEASE THE INFORMATION SO
THEY CAN GET ANSWERS.
>> Sean: LAST QUESTION.
EXIT QUESTION.
CONGRESSMAN DeSANTIS AND
GAETZ, WE WILL START WITH YOU.
CONGRESSMAN DeSANTIS.
WOULD IT BE WEAKER, BETTER FOR
THE COUNTRY THAT THE PRESIDENT,
THAT HE DEMAND THE DOCUMENTS
CONGRESS HAS BEEN OBSTRUCTED
FROM GETTING, SHOULD HE
DEMAND?
>> I THINK SO.
JIM JORDAN, MARK MEADOWS AND I
SENT HIM A LETTER COUPLE WEEKS
AGO URGING HIM TO DO THAT.
HE HAD THE POWER AND I THINK HE
SHOULD DO IT.
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE DESERVE THE
TRUTH ON THIS.
DONALD TRUMP HAS BEEN TREATED AS
POORLY AS ANYBODY BY SOME OF
THESE JOKERS.
HE SHOULD DEFINITELY PULL THE
TRIGGER ON THAT.
>> TOTALLY AGREE, SEAN.
TOTALLY AGREE.
ABSOLUTELY.
THE PRESIDENT HAS THE POWER TO